the average rating is slightly over 1800
so Cube fanatics one-minute war zone
raided 103 players
18:03 average rating time handicap 30
minutes here we go
craziness let's go come on I need to get
a good start am I gonna get a good start
Anton and time cubed this is Anton cubed
right here let's go in time cubed
no not cubes squared by typo that's a
blunder right from the beginning
that's a blunder right from kickoff
right there it's not cubes squared
that's what you meant you're trying to
be clever
oh let's see three I have a feeling
we're gonna see C 3 ok I've played this
guy enough where I was actually able to
recall that that's what they do
let's get this horsey in here and pin
that night we're not let's not there's
got to be uncomfortable the Queen scared
she's scared let's stop d4 let's get my
Bishop active chop and then chop here or
I get here okay I get there
or here I get there or here I get where
pressure on this maybe one day one day
Bishop here Knight here Queen trade pawn
takes it's a little scary rook up it's a
bit awkward I could take here maybe that
would have been good clock situation
okay I'm just gonna run away right here
and I want a knight on that four can I
make that happen right here looking at
me whoa whoa hang on
right here I'm opposite that between oh
I got this I got the rook next oh that's
not working hang on let's come over here
for a second I thought I'm the bish the
bishop could have just taken oh oh oh
back up back up what's the time I want
to take this bishop let's get out of
there first rook get out of there I need
a flight square as well
I could sneak this in first I have the
Knights are covering down there I want
to get this in though flight square on a
light square or a dark square everywhere
blunders commentary blunders let's go
Knights time pressure time pressure time
pressure no time time burners
where are the time burners right here
would have been me that would have been
a cool mane
they're down on time though the dawn of
time the down on time to somebody as for
the assassin is up there everybody
should fear the assassin everybody 27h
pine that's not my H pun this is my H
Vaughn right here let's get him going
and that's not do that my pond would
fall here oh what's going on kitchen
sink variation the kitchen sink I'm
getting kitchen sink right here quick
resign or not no they're still playing
on stay around here night it's probably
stuff gonna happen open this up right
here hit that g6 pun pressure on g 6g 6
g 6g 6 no i didn't want it to I want an
opinion
I wanted to pin it with Queen to h4
instead this that pond could have found
real soon my bishop is hit let's back up
and now Knight here is uh hitting stuff
isn't it let's just take and play here I
would love to get this in takes and then
g3 okay this is a good spot it's here
castle rook to e1 keep this rook right
where it's at I could always should've
taken here I could have done that now I
can't let's run over here it's probably
safer
flight square or a better Elvin Bishop
here Bishop here on eight six
what's this Knight up to let's come over
here it's safer Bishop here I guess real
soon
right now I'm gonna be up a rook now
more than just that back rank mates back
rank mates
the rook is gonna have to defend I just
want to take here after the rook blocks
pin this is a difficult pin to get out
of why don't go there at my bishop why
did I just take that boy check check
check check check check
come here grab a pawn pin and Knight
kill the night TKO the rooks cooked no
time no time no time no time they did
they resign it back to Turman 12 6 ok 12
and then a bunch of sixes no surprised
who's up top mr. cap
Oh quick resigner we're tied 12 12 and a
bunch of sixes double those points going
all-in
all or nothing another command there ok
maybe one of one of them not not a lot
of them oh I thought this was the leader
I thought this was the pack leader Cesar
Millan this isn't Cesar Millan first I
saw the sea and I thought it was cap cap
rock it's not capper out though
okay so Queen c7 fishing let's go
fishing go fish not the card game the
combo not the card game the combo push
this fish up around get my bishop on b7
you know you want to do that put
pressure on this pawn eventually if
there's chops let's do this why'd I do
that play d6 ok I have that dark square
bishop this no let's do that first I
don't want this pawn push to come in
then I could play here Oh
let's come over here I'm scared I think
there would have been sacrifices on
these squares maybe night there was best
let's do it now the knight has to run
away scared if I am threaten them like
I didn't threaten them but okay here and
then Bishop here Oh dark square
weaknesses dark square weaknesses Bishop
g7 all the more appealing C file opening
up don't recapture it the pond the rook
wants to stay here pressure on the
knight more pressure on the knight with
Queen c7 this is close to main right
where's the mate
let's take with this I'm on the Queen
discovered tricks in the air I'm on the
Queen they should resign are they gonna
resign they're not resigning should I be
surprised don't be surprised it happens
all the time it happens you're not just
gonna get people rolling over Jerry
you're not just gonna get people rolling
over they're gonna make you earn it
they're not just gonna resign that's
more pep talks everywhere okay here we
go back to term in 30 20 2012 let's go
so far so good but I have a feeling I'm
gonna hit a speed bump at any moment any
moment it could happen oh no fantasy
variation mainline Carol or not okay
well it's gonna turn out to be a more
solid game right and there's an annoying
pin my bishop has to run back because I
don't like pins let's break those pins
please let's just break those pins
please chop here chop here recapture
there clean trade coming up let's do
this back up to g3 where it's protected
pawn push pawn push twice pawn push once
I need to watch over f4 recapture here
guard this pawn break I should have went
out over the other rook that was the
wrong Rupp to go with if PI if Knight
here I take with my bishop I think yeah
okay Knight do something you want to be
here you know you want to be here you
watch over this square bishop my other
Brooke gets here now okay they're doing
a good job
get rid of that Knight is their plan
maybe I should have considered Bishop h4
I still have a good Bishop if there's a
check I think I lose upon let's come
over here I thought Queen b6 and then
Queen takes b2 I need a flight square
this seems good double up on this file
or
what other file let's try this one Queen
er Brooke here's gonna be played no it's
not I think that an opportunity for that
maybe I just want to take this pawn out
and probably a good idea to get out off
of this diagonal let's do it
pancakes here let's do this prong push
maybe get in c5 or something no okay
more pawns fixed on dark squares for
black let's watch over this over here my
Brooke wants to be on d5 multi-purpose
lateral attack and pressure in this my
queen is a controlling stuff in now
inducing more weaknesses seventh-ranked
issues now okay what's the plan let's
get some more pawns up here a little
scary a little scary let's do that I'm
not sure what do it
Queen check I'm not gonna take I want to
keep this pawn right here those rooks
are stuck over here twelve seconds this
is slow this is a slow game it's a slow
position what can you do now there's a
pawn push why did I allow that let's get
back here I could have taken the pick up
as well let's take them now take free
pieces
Wow take free pieces how many times do I
have to tell myself that if there's free
pieces just take them take the free
pieces okay let's go here times time
situation just no matter what I take
here maybe back to term at forty two
forty two thirty five thirty thirty
let's go Jonathon c5 for the win okay
and let's get this pawn up let's get my
knight up pawn push oh I don't know
about that night obstructing this uh
that epon can I get this move in can i
let's do this I'm not sure why
just take that can I get the dark square
bishop I don't want this this that's a
giant Thor and if it gets in there
no giant thorns let's get this in what
are they doing
Queen check okay I get this move in
what's that Knight up to I got check
over here I'm gonna take and then take
here
I have this move available I'm on the
Queen I'm on forks forks forks width
check first and then no no no no what am
i doing right here get that clean and
then shut down that dark skirt no they
resigned back to tournament Oh
somebody's in the lead though okay 61
I'm in second Ark Ark Angel Archangel
107 let's try the Smith Morra well known
actually that was that was the out Alpen
I misspoke right there so setting up you
know what let's go for it
oh the anti that stops that but my H
Punk could cause some damage very easily
very easily the H pun no not so fast
my knight wants to be on g4 because it's
on f6 and I could play f4 I think I
think that's a good idea to get an F for
my bishops developed here my other
bishop could be where Queen b6 is
probably good oh that pawn is falling or
not or it is you decide you decide o
scariness scariness this is not good
this is not good
pressure time time to panic is it time
to panic
I think it's time to panic
Oh time is tickin their time to stick in
maybe they're scared are they scared
night check let's try it even if it's
wrong punch pawn push get these guys
we're all and grab this pawn they might
do pawn push
I might ignore and Oh
I might do what I rip takes pawn is
maybe available
opposite color Bishop this Knight is
difficult to remove oh let's do that and
oh I'm just getting a piece now they're
down on time I got a piece and more more
pieces are falling this is a pin tricky
discoveries time burners time burners
where are they right here
wartime burners where are they back to
tournament they're down on time 72 59 Oh
cap slipped up
the guy was in second place slipped up
or he wasn't first he slipped up okay
alright I have a slight lead a slight
lead here why did I get into this dry
position right here now it's my opponent
who's gonna be hitting me with the
fishing pole maybe okay here's the plan
get rid of light square bishop actually
let's scratch that plan don't drop
pieces don't you dare drop pieces Bishop
e5 would have done just that
let's try something different like
getting your night out putting pressure
on that pawn although the bishop defend
if I take the bishop let's back up here
if I take the bishop fight I can't
complete my thoughts if I take the
bishop this file would open up let's do
this Bishop here would have been
annoying I don't really want to give up
my dark square Bishop but I might have
to cuz that Knight is a giant pain get
rid of the giant pain maybe b6
let's try b6 oh I just dropped upon no I
didn't I gotta come over here yes I did
there's big problems I gotta come here
what an ugly ugly ugly spot for a knight
to be what an ugly spot oh the Queen's
are coming off this is a problem this is
what you call a problem right here Oh
more pieces falling everywhere hit the
Queen just trade give me that light
square bishop please why don't you give
me the light square bishop pants pins
I'm on this what's the clock count it's
even oh but there's more pressure
oh this is scary this is scary and all
the Queen's are coming off are they
gonna come off Queens Queens Queens
Queens Queens hang on hang on hang on
clock clock clock where are the time
burners no oh I got to do this rook
takes Bishop now I have an in-betweener
I would have had an in-betweener for
that wow that was a good move okay
they're down on time though that's my
best friend
once again the clock is my best friend
that's all I have no skill just all-time
save the day trader rook rook takes pawn
is available come on they're down on
time back to turn 9390 cap is back up
there he will not be long off ever he is
always right around the corner right
around the corner cap or ruski less than
15 minutes remaining there might be
night takes here okay let's Castle D for
D for I can't get D for in let's stop a
pin with H 3 as soon as that pawn moves
nope there's not gonna be any pin pon
takes where don't want to go of my night
let's see if I get the F file give me
the F file okay I get the bishop pair I
want to get an F for I want to
eventually take on this square it could
happen real soon Queen f3 not so fast
we enough to Queen here mean we're queen
g3 I like Queen g3 my opponent can I
move Queen g3 Queen g3 pressure um I
also might want to go after the King if
they go Queen side with rook to b1a4 a5
stuff there is no Knight move actually
there is a knight move the Queen is
defending the bishop let's get that
Bishop out of there and if it backs up
here I back up here and if they take I
have the a file and they're going astray
I think that a [ __ ] go back here I
think taking that pond is good now the
knight cannot be making use of h5 and I
back my bishop up and then I'm on the
knight again the knight has to go to a
different square probably d7 I think
weenie seven Bishop back 90s and they d7
is forced and then my queen has this
square available but they're not moving
ten seconds left or black oh let's just
back up I went that night there's no
time there's absolutely no time time
burners I don't want any time to come
off my clock they're down a time 110 113
113 110 and third is 76 let's go let's
go let's go let's go
Oh more of this I'm gonna take with my
queen just to make it a little bit more
dynamic here I make that happen
pawn push oh okay let me get this out
oh my light square bishop to do
something better than staring at a pond
let's back up pin night here what do I
do
let's get here pile up on this guy hang
on Knight takes is that available maybe
Bishop here I wonder I wanted to get
this pun it's my plan let's do this this
knight is pinned maybe push that push is
coming whoa
I really didn't expect that to happen
get that night out of there and then
play here I could take here with check
there's no in-between move oh so much
for getting this poem I would just say
that the whole time yeah let's get that
part yeah you're really gonna get him
now that he's an e pawn right here get
this guy maybe b5 get these get this
majority going it's a four and three
chip away at this guy get this Bishop on
this diagonal back up Queen wants to be
right here right here looking for tricky
mates looking for tricky mates no that
would have dropped a queen don't drop
your Queen checker ruski where are the
checks where are the checks where the
mates where the mates it's a me it's a
million to me oh I didn't realize that
one 31 21 11 minutes and change the
assassin is right there everybody should
fear the assassin marshal
Marshall Marshall Marshall 183 let's go
here okay okay let's do this I have a
space advantage generally speaking you
want to keep more pieces on the board
when you have a space advantage and
generally speaking you don't want to be
launching your H pond let's it's a
bullet game okay but wait a second
Bishop g5 get out of there Knight
maybe I should have went Bishop here
first is the knight gonna run home he's
going home he's going home they're in a
pickle my opponents in a pickle bishop
here big problems this part could be
taken I missed that I want to get this
pawn and push away to a queen uh-oh
they're in a giant now if I take here I
end up getting pinned let's not take
care then queenside castle inside castle
clock situation
what's this knight doing is he gonna
bother me I just play here I don't want
to move my queen I think she's good here
yeah I don't want to drop this pawn
either let's get the cleanup guard some
stuff here
just push this pawn and I think that's
gonna be TKO no good solution to this
this H pun really uh
cause black some problems getting it
that deep like that
Oh are they gonna resign resign Bishop
f6 pawn push get a queen no kitchen sink
I'm getting kitchen sink right now 1514
let's take here pieces are falling more
pieces are falling Queens are off the
board pawns are pushing checks are in
the air
tricky checks Forks pins skewers Knights
cooked Knights pre-move anything I don't
want my time to tick
no more time off my clock anything
anything
okay back to chairman 150 151 152 it
just can't be easy
there's no runaways in these tournaments
a minute's a change Kappa rot it's still
right there right there making me earn
everything ah quick resigned I kept the
bishop know okay okay maybe I could get
them in a primo or something I'm trying
to get it trying to get it I don't want
that pond to be able to capture like
that I want to keep my Queen right where
she's at um can I get this come on take
that night take that night it's probably
good to take it I should take my queen I
would've been on the night they're darks
where weaknesses my knight wants to be a
traveler so that would mean I don't know
what that means and then he wants to be
a traveler okay whatever you say
whatever you say he wants me a traveler
okay give checks break open the position
oh man I don't realize some of these
things that I say he wants to be a
traveler I don't know what that means
all right he oh he wants to reposition
that's what I meant
it's grab a pun so that this guy is free
to roam free to roam free to roam
meaning pass punt land let's go here
let's go here with check and then keep
pushing keep pushing
check the Queen's are lively pins
everywhere grab a rook grab a pawn
discover checks that's me back to
tournament 171 176 minutes and change no
I thought I was playing black and this
doing the Sicilian right there that
wasn't
thing that was it Oh and now I'm over
but the stakes have been doubled six
minutes six minutes left here's the
clock this guy's not moving the points
have been doubled though the game stakes
have been doubled it says so let me pre
move this and see what's going on
elsewhere let's see I got to do some
homework
what's Kappa rot doing let's root for
Kappa rots opponent come on this is
close come on black come on black you
got it
you gotta give me you gotta do it
checkmate checkmate checkmate yes oh
look at the standings look at the
standings I'm gonna bleed I'm in the
lead 170 169 oh the tables turn I'm
gonna getting some juicy points for this
one Oh
ten seconds left ten seconds left
oh oh oh five four three two one give me
the points show me the points show me
the points plus 21 91 69 let's roll
c5 for the win come on keep going don't
think you have it in the bag don't you
dare start counting those chickens no
chicken counting don't you dare even
start any of that let's try this let's
count the UH let's count the okay let's
get the center what am I trying to say
count the fish count the fish okay what
are they gonna do chop right here I want
my queen to give me right here be sneaky
be sneaky be sneaky I'm being sneaky oh
I missed that move no don't take my
knight take this pine you know you want
to take this pawn take it it's free are
there or there it's leading some eight
just move just move just move just move
yes they moved to ten
do 10 whoa whoa whoa whoa oh that's not
even that cap anymore
the cab was overtaking spinal tap is up
there spinal tap - okay let's go more
development more development okay I'm
okay with this cuz I get the the file
and stuff I'm ready to take gonna give
me the D file they're gonna give me this
they're gonna give me a pun and now they
can't castle the bishop is an animal
he's got to run away though he was
scared of the night this night needs to
go he's got to go give me the a file
let's try this opposite color Bishop
pending who stands better I want to get
the Queen how can I get the Queen can I
get the Queen let's get an F for this
and then they're there now we're ready
to get the Queen get the Queen get the
Queen I got the Queen are they gonna
resign you know you want to resign power
of suggestion you know you wanna resign
yes they knew they weren't wanna resign
right there - 3189 they're battling out
for second place maybe do I have this
locked there's three minutes and change
another resigner oh that's gonna seal it
that's got a seal right there there's no
way that's the third resigner I'm not
the first place without that happening
don't do that make me earn it even
though I say quick resign and I don't
really mean it I don't really mean it
let's go castle D for D for there's
three minutes and change left is there
gonna be a pen Bishop g4 I don't get is
into the game if I have to if I if
there's a lead like that 250 I'm at 250
oh that was a mouse slip I wanted f4 I
got to watch out for maybe this now all
right let's do that my queen is tied on
to the bishop queenside castle I get
this guy or maybe not here is best I
want to keep the Queen's on maybe Queen
check and grab here although Queen check
c6 the Queen guards it laterally Rupp d1
what's this queen up to she's ready to
come here to trade
whoa pressure Forex c7 problems two
minutes 24 seconds in the tournament 224
if I could win this quick and then maybe
get one more in maybe 17 16 15 14
they're just gonna burn their clock this
is no they're not gonna do that keep
focused here I could take this the queen
with the rook I'm just gonna do this no
matter what no time no time no time
anything any mole of any move any move
any move any move they're down on time
back to term at 270 239 195 one minute
45 chess Skype one minute 41 so how many
seconds do I have I have to I have to
win with about 20 seconds remaining on
my clock so I have about a half a minute
half a minute to win it come on go fish
goldfish goldfish goldfish goldfish go
fish my square weaknesses get on the
light squares pawn push I take the
knight I take the knight I got the Queen
I got the queen I got the Queen I got
the Queen that might resign they're
gonna resign one minute 13 seconds being
sneaky I still have the Queen she's not
going anywhere they're not resigning
they're gonna be a clock partner no they
resigned that was a beep position 292 59
one minute we're warning one minute
warning massive pawn efore 55 seconds I
have to go for a quick win quick win
throw the bishop right on this pond
mating once right
oh it's parried Knight here I insist
making one threat maintenance I got to
try one movers another making one threat
and it's been foiled I tried okay hang
on maybe guys stuff something more
brewing right here take the bishop and
give me uh-oh check wait this might be
me wait it might be me give a check grab
here give a check here I'm gonna resign
check where's the mate where's the meat
where's the mean there's no mean
there's no mate they're not resigning 12
seconds 12 seconds whoa whoa watch I
don't get made it I was close to get it
made it right there I'm getting up made
it down here maybe Oh tournaments over
tournaments over tournaments over
tournaments over what's the clock
situation what do I got first place
confetti I'll take it
I always try my best with those one move
mate threats not without that help
though I'm not up top there without that
help 290 279 215 and what else
so those were the two hundred pluses
good games ah 19 in 23 and 15 in okay 23
games is a lot